make sure that you take care of the people that are on your team.
Okay, make sure that you take care of the people that are on your team.
And I'm telling you right now, if the business owners that you work with,
you don't care about them, that the people that are on your team are going to notice
and they're going to think in their head, you know what, if he's treating the business owner
like that, you know, he can't possibly care about me. And they're probably right.
Okay. But just remember that at the end of the day,
you are not going to be able to scale this business without people on your team.
You may be able to get to 10,000, you may be able to scrap your way to 15, 17,
$20,000 per month, and you're going to be running around like crazy, doing it all yourself.
But if you truly want to scale, if you want to make big boy money, big girl money,
20, you know, 50,000, 70,000, a hundred thousand dollars a month, a million dollars a year,
you have to have a team. Okay. I don't care how much work you're willing to put in. I don't care
how much hustle, how much sweat, which I think you're stupid to be able to do that. I would
much rather make $40,000 and do 10 hours of work and free up the other 30, 40 hours a week to go
and grow it even more. Right. I'd way rather do that than do all the work and make a million
dollars. Right. Cause my capacity is only that a million dollars. But for those of you that
truly want to make this happen, you are going to need people on your team.
I'm telling you, make sure you take care of them. Make sure that their concerns,
their needs, their, you know, their goals, their dreams, they are important to you
as much as yours are important to you.